victor h ou via veuve de cette ruche ou
via bonjour doria souvient merci de
répondre à nos questions ce matin gérard
c'est france on vient donc de le dire un
live play a révélé hier que lors des
auditions les policiers impliqués dans
la mort de votre mari ont contesté le
fait d'avoir perçu des signes de son
asphyxie votre réaction quand vous avez
appris cette nouvelle
je vais pas vous cacher que c'est vous
qui venez de me l'apprendre je pense que
c'est une suite logique de ce qu'ils ont
mis en place c'est à dire sauver notre
peau à tout prix donc tous les coups
sont permis
comme vous le savez depuis le départ il
ya énormément de monde change énormément
d'incohérence entre la réalité des faits
est ce que les policiers ont déclaré
c'est à dire ne pas avoir été violent ne
pas l'avoir touché comme quoi qu'il
serait tombé tout seul
donc tout ça c'est une suite logique
maintenant je vais vous dire on reste
quand même confiant malgré tout étant
donné que qu'il ya des expertises qui
sont assez sérieuse et poussé dans qu'on
attend et voilà au jour d'aujourd'hui
nous on a un enregistrement audio
ou est-ce qu'on entende bien
distinctement mon mari donc leur
demander les supplier de le lâcher
par la suite ces derniers mots ça va
être j'étouffe j'étouffe j'étouffe il
l'a dit un rassemblement et et bien
distinctement pour leur dire à la finale
tu verras c'est vraiment vidéo je me
permets de vous couper les trois
policiers mis en examen pour homicide
involontaire en juin d'enregistrements
audio excusez moi c'est un
enregistrement audio
c'est à dire que pendant mon mari je
suis choqué l'enregistrement était
toujours en cours en fait
l'enregistrement de du du micro de son
casque vous rappeler les faits quand
même on a trois personnes qui s'appuie
dessus donc la tête de mickaël perez est
quasiment collé à celle de mon mari
ils portent pas de casque intégral sa
visière et relevé donc
en fait il sans limites face contre face
mais en entendant il n'aurait pas pu
l'entendre mais je me permets de vous
dire ce qui a été dit en entendant
alliés gpn l'enregistrement en juin de
votre défunt mari ils se sont dit
catastrophé c'est leur mot ils ont été
expliqués devant les juges que les cris
d' alerte de cédric joue via était
couvert par le bruit ambiant et par les
klaxons au bord d'une route très
fréquentée comment ce que vous réagissez
à cela mais moi je dis que c'est de la
mauvaise soir après bombe h est de bonne
guerre dans le sens où dès le départ il
n'y a pas eu de regret il n'y a pas eu
d'erreur pour ainsi dire puisque ya pas
eu d'aveux il n'y a pas eu de
manifestations de leur part ils ont rien
dit se son compteur contenter d'espérer
d'espérer qu'ils soient pas punis et
espérer que ça passe à travers d'espérer
qu'ils aient pas de preuve qui est pas
de vidéo qui est pas de témoignage en
fin de compte ça a été tout l' inverse
et heureusement pour nous et donc comme
je vous disais il s'agit d'un
enregistrement audio en sachant qu'on
n'a pas que ça ont heureusement quand on
a de la chance on en a vraiment dans
notre malheur puisque on a également un
témoin qui passait pas très loin de là
bas et qui aurait même voulu sauver mon
mari mais bon vu qu'il est vu qu'il est
violentée par des policiers c'est un peu
c'est un peu délicat de s'interposer
entre la police à un citoyen mais qui a
entendu la voix de mon mari donc il
était à quelques mètres il a je vais pas
vous mentir il n'a pas entendu vraiment
ce qu'il disait mais il a entendu la
voix de mon mari donc quand vous avez ce
témoignage
et puis quand vous regardez les vidéos
enfin je veux dire
mais bien sûr toujours cette présomption
d'innocence avec laquelle je suis
d'accord donc on attend les retours
d'expertisés notamment sur les décibels
de toute évidence vous dites moi c'est
des menteurs
voilà qui ont commis l'impardonnable
l'intolérable
c'est pour moi c'est décrit milano rue
en uniforme et là la seule carte qu'ils
ont à jouer c'est le mensonge et la
mauvaise foi donc c'est une suite
logique des événements quoi les pros
policiers ont
je reste confiance voilà bon la justice
pour pour apporter voilà tous les moyens
techniques à lenquête pour pour
contredire justement tous leurs
mensonges
les policiers présumé coupable donc ont
été mis en examen pour homicide
involontaire en juin dernier en juin
dernier
en juillet dernier en juillet oui en
juillet dernier est-ce que c'est
suffisant pour vous complètement mais
non pas du tout enfin je veux dire on le
sait bien si le même acte avait été
commis par des citoyens lambda enfin je
veux dire
déjà il y aurait sûrement une garde à
vue et puis même
enfin nous quand on a rencontré le
ministre on a vu qu'il était dans une
position un peu délicate
il nous a expliqué qu'il attendait déjà
avéré donc les chats à vérifier quoi
c'est des éléments qui montrent leur
implication et leur responsabilité dans
la mort de mon mari
donc nous on a des rapports d'expertisé
aujourd'hui au niveau musical qui
conclut en disant que bon pas de cette
forme là mais grosso modo il explique si
cédric n'avait pas croisé ces quatre
policiers
il serait toujours vivant donc il n'y a
aucun aucune relation avec son état de
santé comme on a pu entendre dans les
débuts il a fait un malaise cardiaque il
était en mauvaise santé
non mon mari il avait des petits
problèmes d'hypertension qui étaient
traités
j'ai rencontré son cardiologue par la
suite il m'a dit écoutez si si si si ce
n'est pas mentir les expertises et que
vous avez un rapport qui dit comme quoi
que votre mari avait un problème au
coeur il m'a dit je démissionne de ma
profession et les gens s'indigne c'est
des gens sauf les bonnes personnes parce
que moi cette police en fait solidaire
dans le mon sens solidaire dans la
méchanceté gratuite solidaire dans la
lâcheté c'est pas de la bonne solidarité
soyez solidaires pour vos vraies causes
pour vos vraies valeurs
vous êtes là pour nous protéger pour ne
se courir moi mon mari d'annie étaient
protégés ils sont quand même 4 donc j'ai
une peau lisse
hier qui au jour d'aujourd'hui elle est
témoin assisté pour moi cette femme
c'est pas un témoin assisté à l'est les
complices elle est impliquée
voilà c'est un mélange en fait il ya des
méchancetés il ya de la violence il ya
bien l'acheter parce qu'on a deux jeunes
stagiaires donc que ben oui
effectivement c'est peut-être parce
qu'ils avaient prévu pour ce jour là
merci beaucoup dans les hlm avoir
d'avoir répondu à 12 ans monsieur je
rappelle que vous êtes donc la veuve de
cédric souvient